tu va goûter de ma botte secrète à la
toucher tu vas payer traîtres a dit me
retenir
qu'est-ce que s'arrête mais contre qui
tu bats turc emprunt petit marquis amis
du comte de gisha le compte de 10 ch et
camille sophonie c'est un art rock
c'est un pic c'est un cap quand dijon
cap
c'est une péninsule à messieurs casimir
de bergerac pour vous servir la vidéo je
ne savais pas que tu connaissais cyrano
de bergerac
vois tu me sous-estiment toujours en
tout cas ce chapeau est super mais je
suis bourré formidable pour vous pensez
que c'est un déguisement réussi pour le
goûter costumés ont battu pouvait pas
trouver mieux
c'est une idée très originale c'est un
scandale
me suis dit ce n'est que vous
arrive-t-il
j'étais venu vous faire admirer le
costume que je m'étais choisi pour le
goûter costumés mais je m'aperçois qu'il
va falloir que je choisisse un autre
pourquoi il vous fait vraiment très bien
et je retrouve mes marques dans l'eau
sachez tout d'abord monsieur que je ne
cherche pas à être rigolo et maintenant
permettez moi de répondre à mes amis
notre charge julie vous êtes excuse
d'avoir remarqué que mon costume me va
bien
je vais donc le quitter un regret mais
une personne de ma qualité ne peut
porter le même déguisement qu un
lourdeau il est trés quoi qu'est ce que
c'est moi à lourdes aux illettrés
c'est scandaleux
d'abord je suis même plutôt svelte
je trouve que j'ai même un peu maigri
ces derniers temps vous ne trouvez pas
peut-être tu sais casimir c'est
difficile à juger comme ça d'un seul
coup d'oeil
et puis je ne suis pas un électron j'ai
même dans mes moments de bonheur lorsque
farce à l'océan inondé le soleil
je sens monter jusqu'à moi le délicat
parfum du gloubiboulga que prépare ma
cousine gertrude l'humeur plus tôt
poétique à pouet oui monsieur poète est
tellement que je vais tout en
ferraillant up à l'impro visage vous
composez une balade
c'est incroyable il récite exactement
cyrano de bergerac
la pièce d'edmond rostov une balade vous
ne doutez pas ce que c'est je crois une
balade donc se compose de trois couplets
de we verre et d'un envoi de 4 à bhl je
vais monsieur tout ensemble en faire une
et me battre et vous touchez monsieur au
dernier verre
non balade du duel
quand l'hôtel bourguignon monsieur de
bergerac foot avec un b litres est ce
que c'est que ça s'est déroulé c'est le
titre en place très amusant rangez vous
attendez je choisis mes rimes il ya j'y
suis je jette avec grâce mon feutre je
fais lentement l'abandon du grand
manteau qui me calfeutrant et jeudi lire
mon espadons et les dogues comeau
céladon agit de la com' star amoucha je
vous préviens cher myrmidon à la fin de
l'envoi
je touche à à vous auriez bien dû rester
neutre où vais-je vous l'art des dindons
dans le flanc sous votre mal seront au
coeur sous votre robe lui que nous
les tokio tact
ding dong ma pointe voltige une mouche a
décidément cette eau peut donc à la fin
de l'envoi
je touche à il me manque une rime en
être à vous rompez plus bien camille
dont c'est pour me fournir le mot
pleutre tac je pars lapointe dont vous
vouliez me faire d'hondt
j'ouvre la ligne je la bouche tient bien
la brosse l'haridon on fera la fin de la
voir je touche on boit prince demande à
dieu pardon je carte du pied jusqu'à
mouche je coupe le fait qu'il a dont à
la fin de l'envoi jeu tout ça
tu m'a étonné kazemi c'était du grand t
à ça a été formidable petit steak
merci mais ce duel n'a mis dans un
appétit incroyable je voudrais un gros
globe boidart une glace aux anchois à
trois boules
oui et puis un gâteau mais attend
casimir
il faut que tu continues à jouer et on
roule c'est la suite de cyrano plus très
bien non et bien cyrano qui n'a plus
d'argent rencontre une dame qui lui
propose de se servir à manger sur un
énorme buffet bon eh bien je vais mangé
le même menu que lui très bien pas comme
cyrano un homme très poli et très digne
il accepte un demi macarons un grain de
reva et un petit verre bo1 c'est tout
absolument